tras la muerte de maradona florecieron
las despedidas los homenajes y los
recuerdos pero también comenzaron a
aparecer los conflictos las
controversias y las causas judiciales
como la que investiga la muerte del
astro el pasado miércoles por un paro
cardíaco en el marco desde esa causa la
policía ya no este domingo la casa y el
consultorio de leopoldo luque el que era
el médico personal de maradona allí
secuestraron computadoras celulares y la
historia clínica de diego armando
maradona los fiscales están tratando de
determinar si pudo haber homicidio
culposo están tratando de ver si el
cuidado que recibió diego armando
maradona después de la operación de
hematoma subdural del 3 de noviembre
pasado era el adecuado la operación que
había realizado como cirujano justamente
leopoldo duque el médico habló con los
medios este domingo y dijo con lágrimas
en los ojos que había hecho todo lo
posible todo lo que estaba en sus manos
y que se ponía totalmente a disposición
de la justicia